have you had a day job since that uh
first
obama video i have not worked in nine to
five since 2009.
eight sorry did you ever envision that
being the case i know you went to a
performing arts school and
i know all actors and and performers
whatever hope for that
but we also know that the chances are
sometimes not in our favor
even for the most talented so did you
when that happened when you were able to
kind of cross over how surreal or
whatever for you was it like um did you
have to pinch yourself did you feel
unworthy for a little bit did you feel
excited
well no i didn't feel unworthy because i
don't feel like i've gotten to that
level of success where i'm just like
whoa you know it's um it's been
i've expected to be to have successes
you know like
that's what i dream of and like that's
what i want so it's been
it's been great and it's been cool it's
been an honor it's been a blessing
um but i never really celebrate because
i i don't feel like
i'm at where i want to be and i've i i
think
i've done some great things and had some
great accomplishments but
i never really celebrate too much
because there's so much further that i
want to go
you know does that make sense like
absolutely
do you think back to that day what if
that girl hadn't have been there and
and said yeah i mean do you think back
to what if i had not only that but
what if i hadn't have done anything with
that obama idea
yeah where would i be right now oh of
course and like it's
it's a it's a massively humbling
thought just like what if that just
never happened where would i be
would i still be back in new york
waiting tables would i be miserable
would i even be acting still
you know um it's a it's a you know and
even
that girl who who made that comment like
i've like i we're friends on facebook
and i've reached out like i
want to reach out to her and be like you
know thank you you know yeah and i
reached out to her once and i was like
hey you know and
i tried to talk like say something but
she never even responded and i don't
know she even remembers who i was you
know but
i wanted to say yo thanks you know
because a lot spun out of that comment
so yeah it's it's interesting
you